le Conseil d'orientation des retraites
le corps doit adopter ce rapport annuel
jeudi 22 juin il a transmis les éléments
à ses membres et la presse de ce jour
sans fait largement l'écho le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est que ce nouveau
rapport questionne il y a quelques mois
le corps évoqué des éventuels déficites
de nos régimes de retraite de l'ordre de
l'épaisseur du trait son président
évoquait même en septembre dernier
ouvrez les guillemets les résultats de
ce rapport ne valide pas le bien-fondé
des discours qui mettent en avant l'idée
d'une dynamique non contrôlée des
dépenses de retraite fermez les
guillemets et ainsi de contester
l'intérêt d'un report de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite
les conclusions apparaissent jeudi font
le constat à peu près inverse
si le rapport salue aussi les effets
positifs de la réforme pour les plus
petites pensions et notamment celle des
femmes le groupe démocrate s'interroge
sur les raisons de se renversement
d'analyse quasi complet
le Haut Commissariat aux plans avait
pourtant clairement pointé difficile
structurel de l'ordre de 30 milliards
d'euros mais les oppositions avaient
préférer relayées les doutes émis par le
Conseil d'Orientation
alimentant ainsi la contestation sociale
notre système de retraite a besoin d'un
pilotage efficace basé sur des analyses
responsables et objectives
manifestement cela n'a pas été le cas il
convient d'en tirer des enseignements au
groupe démocrate nous souhaiterions tout
d'abord que les partenaires sociaux
soient davantage associés au pilotage du
régime général des retraites à l'instar
de la gestion d'agir Carco qui a fait
ses preuves et nous pensons aussi qu'une
réflexion doit être menée sur le
fonctionnement ou le dysfonctionnement
du Conseil d'orientation des retraites
nous aimerions donc monsieur le ministre
connaître votre position sur ces sujets
je vous remercie